Democrats in the mainstream media and
Congress all the way to former
presidents throw cold water on the
impeachment push we will examine the
latest bombshell testimony to parse what
if anything this is all about then Kanye
West spreads the gospel to Joel Osteen
Pope Francis wants to make pollution a
sin and a Dark Horse Democratic
candidate takes a big lead in Iowa all
that and more I'm Michael Knowles and
this is the Michael Noel's show more
bombshell testimony today it's the
bombshell of the bombshells in the
impeachment push to house Trump for
doing we still don't exactly know what
they're trying to ask Trump for doing
right now but we got the bombshell
testimony of Marie
Jovanovic the Ambassador to Ukraine she
must have the information right the
Democrats struck out on their first star
witness then they struck out on their
second star witness now let's see if
three three times is a charm we will get
to that in one second first I've got to
thank our friends over at Rock Auto Rock
Auto is a family business they've been
serving Auto Parts to customers online
for 20 years go to Rock Auto dot-com to
shop for auto and body parts from
hundreds of manufacturers which you
don't need to do when you need auto
parts what you don't need to do is go
into a store I know this because
recently this probably two months ago
now is driving up to San Francisco my
car breaks down in the middle of nowhere
this is very frustrating I toe it I get
to the shop and what are they what can
they do for me it's not like they have
any of the parts you know of course are
very complicated there are a lot of
options so what some guy at the shop
does is he goes online and he orders the
parts and then charges me a lot more
money you don't need to deal with that
goes straight to Rock Auto comm they
have everything from engine control
modules and brake parts to tail lamps
motor oil even new carpet whether it's
for your classic or your daily driver
get everything you need in a few easy
clicks delivered directly to your door
Rock Auto comms catalog is unique the
best part about this this is especially
good for me it's very easy to navigate I
don't know all that much about cars
other than that I like
having them you can go and figure out
exactly all the parts that are available
for your vehicle
choose the brands specifications and
prices that you prefer these guys are so
reliable these guys are so fair and
their pricing they got a great selection
you can always count on low prices you
don't need to game it out over this week
there will be a sale and this week it's
just always very very reasonable prices
all the parts your car will ever need to
go to Rock Auto
dot-com and and when they ask you in the
little box at Rock Auto how did you hear
about us make sure you type in Noel's
canna wles rockauto.com we have a lot to
get to today we will get through this
bombshell testimony I am in Kentucky for
the men are not women and other
uncomfortable truths tour so if you're
in Lexington Kentucky by chance tonight
come on out at the University of
Kentucky we're gonna have a whole lot of
fun but before that we've got to figure
out if the president is gonna stay in
office so you remember last week Bill
Taylor was the big star key witness and
Bill Taylor from the Foreign Service
comes out and he's asked do you have any
information on a quid pro quo on some
crime that Trump committed and he said
no then we have a George Kent he's a
Deputy Assistant Secretary of State they
said do you have information that's
going to ask the president evidence that
Trump committed a crime no so then they
bring in Murray Ivanovich Murray
Ivanovich is a career foreign service
officer she is ambassador to Ukraine GOP
representative mark Meadows gets her on
the stand and he says ambassador
Jovanovic do you have any information of
a crime committed by Trump right this is
what we're all here for and guess what
her answer is not at all madam
ambassador as you see it here before us
very simply indirectly do you have any
information regarding the president in
itíd States accepting any bribes now do
you have any information regarding any
criminal activity that the president of
the United States has been involved with
at all yeah
what's incredible about that clip you
can hear it in her voice he asks a very
direct question do you have evidence of
bribes should take her less than one
second answer nope no evidence do you
have evidence that he's committed any
crime worthy of impeachment no she
should know this going in this is the
main question she's gonna be asked but
she doesn't want to be asked the main
questions she just wants insinuation she
just wants this vague sort of
implication that Trump is doing all
manner of terrible things now when you
get clear on this question it's it
becomes obvious that he hasn't committed
any crime worthy of impeachment but she
wants the vagary and Mark Meadows drills
down and she takes that moment has the
president committed any crimes beat beat
beat no has the committed has the
president received any they were
committed any other crimes beat beat
beat no so you watch that testimony you
say it's kind of a flop right then we
turned to Fox News's Chris Wallace Chris
Wallace who I believe is a registered
Democrat he's one of the more
left-leaning it would appear voices at
that network Chris Wallace I guess he
was watching a different clip because he
was absolutely blown away by the
testimony of Murray Ivanovitch I think
that if you are not moved and we'll have
to wait and see what happens in the
cross-examination but if you were not
moved by the testimony of Murray
Ivanovich today you don't have a pulse
this is a woman who had served in seven
posts for presidents of both parties
over more than 30 years so I'm just
checking here got my two fingers on my
wrist I definitely have a pulse and I
definitely was not moved that's actually
not fair I was moved by the testimony of
Murray Ivanovich but I was not moved to
feel that we need to throw this
president out of office I was not moved
with great sympathy and empathy and
compassion for career bureaucrats I was
not moved at all I was moved to fury
that we are prioritizing
the entrenched federal bureaucracy over
the decision
of the American people in 2016 to elect
Donald Trump president because that is
really what this is all about
you heard her answer to Mark meadow she
doesn't have any evidence of a crime
that Trump committed so what is she
doing there what is she so upset about
what she's upset about is that President
Trump ran in 2016 on hollowing out that
federal bureaucracy draining the swamp
to use his words prioritizing the
Democratic desires of the American
people over the liberal consensus that's
ossified that's unaccountable to anybody
outside of Washington DC she's upset
that he's going after those DC
entrenched interests and they're gonna
try to throw him out of office for it
here she is the State Department is
being hollowed out from within at a
competitive and complex time on the
world stage this is not a time to
undercut our diplomats that sounds like
one of the greatest pitches for Trump
2020 I've ever heard of the State
Department is being hollowed out from
within good I'm glad the State
Department's being hollowed out from
within I don't like how much power the
State Department has I don't like how
independent the State Department has
become unmoored it has become from the
wishes of the American people and from
the executive they are there to serve
the executive they are there to carry
out his policies not the other way
around and we've gotten into a situation
in this country where the tail is
wagging the dog where presidents come
and go but the State Department in
particular is the image of the
entrenched bureaucracy never ever
changes I do not care about Murray
Ivanovitch I do not care what she wants
I do not care how she feels that foreign
policy should be conducted when that
interferes with how the president wants
foreign policy to be conducted I don't
care that the State Department now has
to be more accountable to the American
people I don't care that they're upset
about that I'm very pleased to hear that
that is happening Jovanovic puts her all
of our cards on the table right she says
this is about Trump going after the deep
state or the federal bureaucracy or
whatever you want to call it she goes on
the department's leaders to stand up for
the institution and the individuals who
make that institution still today
the most effective diplomatic force in
the world and Congress has a
responsibility to reinvest in our
diplomacy that's an investment in our
national security it's an investment in
our future in our children's future that
is not the responsibility of the State
Department
she says the responsibility of the State
Department is to defend the State
Department b.s the responsibility of the
State Department is to conduct American
foreign policy at the pleasure of the
president because we we the American
people do not exist to serve the State
Department the State Department exists
to serve us how do they serve us through
our democratic and republican mechanisms
of government we elect the president
she's appearing before the house we
elect members of the House she serves us
but they don't think that way at the
State Department they believe if you go
into the Foreign Service and you're
you've served there for your whole
career and then you end up in some
higher-up diplomatic post you it tends
to be the case that these guys believe
that they have no responsibility to the
American people they know what's best
Murray Ivanovich knows what's best what
does Donald Trump know what did the
American people who elected him now it's
outrageous that he's contradicting us us
the wonderful federal bureaucrats he's
contradicting us on foreign policy so
that guy's got to go and that's what
this whole thing is about this has
nothing to do with a phone call with
Ukraine this has nothing to do with an
investigation into Joe and hunter Biden
there should be an investigation into
John Hunter Biden but that's not what
this is about this has nothing to do
with president Trump's alleged
corruption and the oversight
responsibilities of Congress or the
Constitution or high crimes and
misdemeanors the high crime the
President Trump is committed here is
hurting the feelings of federal
bureaucrats that's not a crime that's
not an impeachable offense actually
every so often it's an important thing
to do to remind those bureaucrats and to
remind those lifelong State Department
employees that they do not have a
mandate by birth to run
government for us they don't we still
run our government maybe we do I mean
that's so much of what the last three
years has been about it's it's what the
2016 campaign was about and it appears
that's what the 2020 campaign is going
to be about do the American people still
have a right to govern ourselves or are
we going to chip away at our sovereignty
or sovereignty as a people and are we
gonna give it to a distant Capitol in
Washington DC and are we going to give
it to entrenched federal interests and
are we going to give it abroad are you
going to give it to international and
supranational institutions like the IMF
or the WTO or the European Union or the
United Nations all of these institutions
that exist to take power away from the
people of independent nations that's how
when people are discussing nationalism
the best version of that conversation is
about how to keep our National Liberty
as a people we are supposed to be a
self-governing
Republic we are not living in a
technocratic dictatorship run by these
lifelong federal employees that's not
where we are maybe that's what you
voinovich wants maybe that's what Chris
Wallace wants I don't know I don't not
putting words in his mouth but I think
when the American people look at that
testimony their jaws drop open and they
say what on earth are they doing what is
this all about
you're gonna you're gonna throw out
Trump even though this woman has no
information about any crime he's
committed you're gonna throw out Trump
cuz he hurt her feelings meanwhile you
cut to Chris Wallace and he says if you
if your heart didn't break for that
woman you don't you don't have a pulse
that is such a removed opinion that is
such an opinion of people in Washington
DC and nobody else and even Democrats
are waking up to this by the way it's
not just Republicans so far this is an
absolutely partisan impeachment which
presents challenges of its own but I
mean there there are not gonna be
Republicans who throw him out the one
Republican who wants to throw President
Trump out has left the Republican Party
that's just an image the rest of them
are not going to do it so you're going
to have the
Democratic Party go in they're still
upset that they lost the 2016 election
they're gonna try to overturn that
election even some Democrats are
breaking rank there's a democratic
representative Jeff van drew who is
throwing cold water on impeachment here
is congressman van drew you've had such
courage and leadership since you took
the job in Congress you are also one of
two who have voted against this increase
to begin with why I just think we're
keep going down this road keep spending
more time you know many of us came to
Congress because we really wanted to
accomplish goals really work on issues
such as health care work on issues
dealing with prescription drugs election
security the debt the deficit you know
the list goes on and I can speak on on
about all the things that we need to do
and I just don't think we're hearing
anything new and real quickly we must
import must understand the importance
and the level of what impeachment is
hundreds of years of history no bun has
ever been convicted of impeachment and
that's the point we're gonna have an
election next year yeah let's have the
election let's we'll fight through the
election let's do what Republicans and
Democrats and whomever else does but
this is gonna get us nowhere we've spent
millions of dollars in my opinion tons
of money tons of time
tons of hurt fraction the nation apart I
haven't seen this to be a good thing so
Jeff Andrew is right about this the
impeachment is pulling the nation apart
and the historical example is really
important here because especially in
recent years we've heard impeachment
bandied about so much that we think it's
a normal thing it's not it's not normal
to impeach the president in fact we have
never once in this nation's history
removed a president from office through
the mechanism of impeachment we had
Andrew Johnson who was impeached and
then acquitted in the Senate then you
wait more than a hundred years and you
get to Richard Nixon Democrats also were
upset that he won that election in a
landslide so they sought to overturn it
they made moves to impeach Richard Nixon
and he resigned before it could happen
then you get to Bill Clinton Bill
Clinton was impeached
but acquitted and then you get during
the Obama administration John Boehner
said that he was never going to impeach
but Barack Obama and then you get to
Donald Trump and they've tried to
impeach him since before he took office
we'll get to that in a second but first
when government resources are strained
it can be days if not weeks before you
can get to fresh food and water if you
have taken anything else away from this
show today I think it should be that you
cannot rely on the government when it
comes to life and death because there's
a lot of dysfunction there you can't
rely on somebody else you have to rely
on yourself don't put yourself in a
situation where you need something that
you don't have get prepared today all of
the ingredients in wise foods are chef
prepared internally by wise company by
doing this they cut out the middleman
and pass the savings on to you all you
need is four cups of water it doesn't
even need to be hot you take the
contents out of the pouch wise foods and
you pour them into the water you stir
you cover that's it in 15 minutes it is
ready to go for your family no matter
what the situation it's really important
the thing I really love about wise foods
it's very high quality stuff on of
course I'm a man of simple tastes I'm
easily satisfied by the very best but
what I like about it is it just reduces
stress I mean I live in LA which
practically burns down every three
months I don't think that I'm gonna end
up in the apocalypse I don't think that
I'm gonna end up with everything going
to hell in a handbasket around me but I
just want the peace of mind to know that
sweet little ELISA is taken care of if
we got it and that I'm taking care of
and my whole family is taken care of
there is no excuse for waiting until
it's too late no better time to prepare
them right now get it get wise foods the
wise emergency food is a great
investment you put it away you don't
have to think about it until you do my
listeners have VIP access to the Black
Friday sales event from my friends at
wise company text wise WI se 229 691 and
you will get a reply with the early
access link if you've been on the fence
about getting prepared or if you're
looking to add more this is the best
time to do it you're going to save a lot
no better time of the year when so many
products are discounted like this some
are actually 70% off that's 7-0 in
addition to that if you text why
229 691 you will be sent a $10 coupon
code that can be used toward any item on
their website no exclusions that is why
this w is e 229 691 as always shipping
is free for my listeners wise 229 691
for ongoing automated text offers from
wise company message and data rates may
apply visit wise food storage comm for
privacy and terms Senate Democrats truck
actually tried to impeach him and set
the stage for impeachment before he took
office shortly after he took office
representative Al Green that's the
congressman not the musician filed a
resolution to impeach President Trump
for what nobody has any idea that one
failed initially then they went after
Russia collusion than it was stormy
Daniels than it was taxes than it was I
don't know they didn't like the cut of
his jib and now they're trying to oust
him over Ukraine and it is tearing the
nation apart you don't need to just take
my word for it or Jeff Andrews word for
it even Barack Obama has implied as much
[Music]
our vision we also have to be rooted in
the enemy and the fact that voters
including these Democratic voters and
certainly persuadable independents or
even moderate Republicans are not driven
by the same views that are reflected on
certain
what leaning fruits or the activist Wang
of our of our party this is silly
country this is less revolutionary than
it is interested in improvement they
like seeing things in food but the
average American doesn't think that we
have to completely turn that a system
when we make it and I think it's
important so that was Obama at an
ostensibly closed-door liberal
fundraiser dinner obviously wasn't that
closed-door what he said is pretty
insightful at the end which is most
Americans don't want a revolution they
don't want to tear down the system he's
urging caution because he thinks like
the Democratic congressman Jeff Andrew
thinks like others believe like Nancy
Pelosi thought for two years that
impeachment ultimately will hurt
Democrats because it's an overreach but
when Obama says most Americans don't
want to tear down the system you've got
to ask yourself what system they're
talking about it's true most I mean this
is backed up by polls we'll get to in a
second most Americans think this
impeachment is BS however it's not as
though we just have the system of
American government and Anarchy those
are not the two decisions those are not
the alternatives we actually have two
competing systems we have the system of
American government the Constitution and
the separation of powers and elections
and power to the people we've got that
and then we have the entrenched
interests of the permanent bureaucracy
that want to run the government
elections be damned that's represented
by Murray Ivanovich and her testimony on
the hill those are two irreconcilable
systems one of them is going to win out
you know Bill Kristol who is the guest
formerly conservative commentator in the
era of Trump he's become a little more
eccentric in his political views a guy I
really actually like personally he was a
teacher of mine but politically now he's
he's really going off the deep end you
would say
when Trump got elected he sent out a
telling tweet he said between the Trump
State and the deep state I choose the
deep State and in fairness to him he
said I'd rather choose neither but
between the Trump state in the deep
state I choose the deep state those are
the two systems that's the battle line
that is being drawn here when you see
people go on television and say oh the
poor bureaucrats
oh the poor lifelong federal agents we
my heart bleeds for them I'm crying for
those people in Washington DC
you realize they've made a decision they
are defending the deep state the
bureaucracy use whatever term you want
and the American people do not want that
that if they're gonna tear down any
system they want to tear down that
system that's so entrenched that it
takes away power from them and they
support our actual system of government
the or at least our old system of
government the Constitution and
elections and you might hate Donald
Trump but between the Trump state and
the deep state you've got to choose the
Trump state because what you're really
saying is between our tradition of
government our Constitution and an
entrenched bureaucracy that has no
accountability you've got to choose your
own self-government if not what are we
even fighting for in these political
games in in America this is all
reflected in polls there's a new
reuters/ipsos poll that's out do you
know what percentage of people are
actually paying attention to impeachment
if you were to look at you know the the
cable news networks if you were to look
at the shattering glass in Washington DC
you would imagine that everybody is
glued to their screens watching
impeachment actually eat among
independents so not the hardline
partisans among independents 36% of
independents said they have not watched
read or heard anything about impeachment
a full 36% of independents have no idea
that this thing is even going on then
when you look at the 60 64 percent of
independents who have paid any attention
to it do you know what what percentage
have actually watched the impeachment
hearings 19%
19% less than one in five independence
is even watching any of this thing then
17% said they watched or listened to
news summaries that's what the the fancy
people on TV and the coats and ties
that's what the Democrats that's what
the left is banking on because they they
don't want to actually see Murray
Ivanovich say I've got no evidence of a
crime they don't want to actually see
Bill Taylor say yeah I don't have any
evidence of a quid pro quo because if
you see that you realize what total BS
this is so instead what you want is
people in suits and ties on TV who have
a political agenda saying this is
bombshell this is devastating our heart
breaks for these federal bureaucrats
then so you got nineteen percent
actually watched at 17 percent say
they've watched or listened to news
summaries 30 percent said they read or
listened to news summaries and now
watching but reading so the poll shows a
huge number of independents have don't
know anything about what is going on and
they are not that engaged among
Democrats obviously the engagement is
much higher thirty five percent or
watching and listening to the hearing
compared to only twenty six percent of
Republicans this is not just a partisan
event in the house this is a partisan
event in the country and it gets even
more crooked the more you look into it
because the whole thing was kicked off
by that so-called whistleblower
allegedly named Eric charmella according
to real clear investigations he's
another one who's a career bureaucrat he
worked at the CIA then he worked for Joe
Biden on Ukraine well Biden was engaging
in corrupt looking schemes in Ukraine
and he worked for John Brennan he just
opposed Donald Trump the intelligence
community Inspector General said there
were three clear pieces of evidence that
he had political bias against Trump Eric
charmella now it turns out is drumroll
please connected to George Soros
left-wing mega donor so this is a new
report that's just out apparently
because emails have been released about
Ukraine policy from a top director at
George Soros as open society foundation
we find out that char amela the alleged
whistleblower was in contact alongside a
number of other Obama administration
foreign policy
officials with George Soros's guys they
were involved about hearing about George
Soros's whereabouts about George Soros's
private meetings about Ukraine and they
were hearing about a future meeting that
the billionaire left-wing activist
George Soros was planning to hold with
the Prime Minister of Ukraine this was
not going through organizing for America
the Obama campaign wing this was going
through the foreign policy apparatus and
through charmella who is a CIA guy who
was then working on Ukraine for Biden
Jeff Goldstein senior policy analyst for
Eurasia at Soros as open society
foundation he sent an email in June of
2016 to eric charmella and ECC two other
state department officials who were also
involved in in european affairs
including the a man named alexander
casanov who was working at the US
Embassy in Kiev this looks more rotten
the more we get into it and by the way
the whole defense of President Trump on
the asking for Ukraine to investigate
corruption was that there was pretty
bizarre interaction going on between the
Obama administration and the federal
bureaucracy the intelligence community
and Ukraine in 2016 well it looks like
we have evidence of that and we have
evidence of that from the most
cartoonishly villainous left-wing
activists in the country George Soros
that is what's going on and it this
relates by the way this this decision
that we've got to make between the Trump
State in the deep state between our
Constitution and the entrenched
bureaucracy this doesn't just have to do
with Ukraine or impeachment this goes to
so many other issues a major one you're
gonna see so many headlines over the
next few days is that President Trump
granted clemency to US troops who were
involved in controversial war crime
cases now the way you're gonna see this
reported in the news is Trump makes
excuses for war crimes
Trump defends war crimes the reality
much more complicated than that
three guys Army First Lieutenant Clint
Lawrence was convicted of second-degree
murder in the death of three Afghans
this is within the past few years Army
Major Matthew gold
faced murder charges next year for what
was being reported as a similar crime
what he actually did was allegedly
murdered a Taliban bomb maker and then
burned his remains in a trash pit which
to me means he should win an Olympic
medal not not be brought for brought up
for war crimes and then the third guy's
Special Warfare operator Chief Edward
Gallagher who earlier this fall was
actually acquitted of a string of
alleged war crimes and he had his rank
restored by the president of chief petty
officer these three guys what what does
this show what is this about why is
Trump granting clemency to these guys
well as you see in the case of Edward
Gallagher we don't know exactly what
they committed right we don't know that
this actually rose to the level of a war
crime as it's being reported in the
press in the case of Gallagher who was
acquitted but what about these other
guys Lawrence and Goldstein let's say
the Goldstein did what they accuse him
of doing that
a Taliban bomb maker was released he got
out and Goldstein was so furious about
this that he killed him Taliban bomb
maker is this the sort of thing that
ought to be encouraged probably not do
we want vigilantism in the military we
want vigilance I guess we don't want
vigilantism but when you send a guy into
a warzone to go kill the Taliban and
then he kills the Taliban bomb maker he
shouldn't have his life ruined for that
and what this really is about is Trump
applying the same rules of
self-governance to the military that
he's applying to the State Department
and the bureaucracy Trump thinks it's
seems that the military has become an
experiment ground for bureaucrats and
sociologists in DC I mean you saw this
with the Obama administration the Obama
administration decided that they were
going to allow people who are men who
identifies women to serve in the
military these are people obviously with
pretty serious psychiatric conditions
who create all sorts of social
challenges for the military because you
don't know exactly where to put them it
would appear that that does not help
military readiness
fitness to fight which is the purpose of
the United States military but
it doesn't matter because for left-wing
activists the military is nothing more
than a social experiment Trump would it
would appear thinks that the military
has become over regulated over lawyered
he thinks that there has become mission
drift and I think he's right I think
it's pretty clear that the much of the
Trump campaign was running against this
kind of nebulous bureaucratic
technocratic malaise even on the use of
the military if you're going to use the
military send them in to accomplish a
goal and then get them out of there
that's his view the kind of liberal
consensus view the permanent state view
is just have the military everywhere all
over the world kind of doing I don't
know what basically just administering a
large global Empire those are two
different views of the country and Trump
is going in there and saying we are
rejecting that we are going to have a
strong American nation and we're not
going to let you regulate our or
military into the ground it's a
controversial decision it's a gutsy
decision there are good arguments on
both sides of this but the the way to
make sense of it is to see how it fits
into his broader vision and it does very
clearly I have got to get to Kanye West
Kanye West headed to I think the largest
mega church in America Joel Osteen's
Lakewood Church and I think this is a
great thing Kanye is catching some flak
for it I think it's wonderful that Kanye
West will spread the gospel to Joel
Osteen we will take a look at that
speaking of the Bible and and religion
we will get to Pope Francis's ideas of
ecological sin and then Pete Budaj is
surging in the race he's up nine points
in Iowa I'm getting texts from Joe
Biden's campaign manager we'll get to
all of that but you got to go to daily
wire.com ten bucks a month hundred
dollars for an annual membership you get
me you get the Andrew Clavin show you
get the Ben Shapiro show you get the
Matt wall show you get to ask questions
in the mailbag you get another Kingdom
you get everything and you get the
leftist here's tumblr go to daily
wire.com we'll be right back with a lot
more
Kanye West is spreading the Gospel
message to the pastor of one of the
largest churches in America I think this
is a great thing it's Joel Osteen now I
have been accused of being unsure table
toward Joel Osteen Joel Osteen if you
don't know him he's that really smiley
guy who goes on TV and speaks in sort of
vaguely Christian language but he
doesn't talk about Jesus
particularly much Joel Osteen gets
lumped in with what is called the
prosperity gospel which is a very
pernicious heresy that transforms that
the true gospel into a sort of feel good
at life-coaching be a good person and
talk to God and you'll make a lot of
money here is Joel Osteen and his wife
they're here the Osteen's preaching the
prosperity gospel just to give you some
context I am blessed I am strong I am
talented I am disciplined I am focused I
am prosperous this morning you know this
would you be happy when you come to
church when you worship Him you're doing
it for yourself because that's what
makes you happy I want you to get a
bigger vision there are exciting things
in your future your future is filled
with marked moments a blessing increase
promotion God has already ordained
before the foundation of the world the
right people the right opportunity time
and chance are coming together for you
why don't you get your hopes up why
don't you start believing that no matter
what you have or haven't done that your
best days are still out in front of you
what Joel Osteen talks about is I am
really good I am really great your best
life now you are meant to have a really
great life here on earth that is not the
message of the gospel the message of the
gospel is pick up your cross and bear it
if you would follow me the message of
the gospel is
the martyrs who who give their lives for
Christ he who seeks his life will lose
it but he who loses his life for me will
have his life abundantly and forever
that's the message of the gospel it's
not the prosperity gospel and so the
fact that Kanye West is going to this
church I think is a great thing I mean
it I am joking a little bit that one of
the most famous rappers in the world is
going to share Christianity - Joel
Osteen but I mean it - I listen to all
of Kanye's album and listen to it twice
and I couldn't find very much wrong with
it with one small exception I found it
to be theologically sound and Kanye went
and gave his Christian testimony of this
church and it rang very sincere there's
documentation of me drawing a church and
saying writing a started church in the
middle of Calabasas and even after that
I went and made the the life of Pablo
album I said this is a gospel album and
I didn't know how to totally make a
gospel album and the Christians that
were around were - I would say beaten
into submission by society did not speak
up and profess the gospel - you know to
me because I was a superstar so but the
the only superstar is Jesus I love that
line it's so simple but it's such a
great line yeah I was a superstar but
the only superstore is Jesus this
reminds me of this woman who I just saw
the other night at the live-action gala
in DC woman Jonna Jessen who survived an
abortion and so she's got a lot of
physical problems as a result of this
attempt to kill her when she was still
in the womb and she gets up there to
accept a reward and give her speech and
speech was very simple she said it's all
about Jesus it's not that complicated
it's about Jesus Jesus saved my life
Jesus is my the sum total of my life and
you all should believe in Jesus and
that's more or less what Kanye is saying
Kanye West conveyed more gospel in his
one day at Lakewood Church than many
many many televangelists have ever given
out in their entire lives and and
conveyed throughout their entire careers
and Kanye talks about what that means
what it's meant for his career and he he
goes on and to me it all sounds urgent
and sincere Vegas they got posters up
advertising you know sex trafficking
because if there's an advertisement for
a strip club that is advertising sex
trafficking because at the end of the
night when they close up the the manager
says how much traffic do we have so if
it's a man that's going through things
with his family are going through things
at work and he feels he has to go there
we all end up participating whether it's
the spirits that get advertised to us
all the time
alcohol is they call it a spirit so we
get constant advertisement for spirits
we get constant advertisement for strip
clubs and other things like that but
then we bring up the name of Jesus we're
told be quiet quiet that down so even
for someone who's professing God and
saying this is gonna be a guy a gospel
album the devil is gonna come and do
everything he can to distract people
from knowing how to fully be in service
to the Lord that is profound and
insightful from beginning to end I mean
I joke with sweet little ELISA now when
we drive and see billboards in Hollywood
that they get so racy that they're not
even titillating they're not even sexy
they're just absurd they're their
grotesque almost I mean pretty soon your
job every billboard is just gonna be
flesh it's not gonna be particularly
attractive or alluring that's the
direction it's trending in for Kanye to
recognize the pun of spirits that
spirits right are opening yourself up to
certain spirits perhaps that there is a
spiritual world in the first place I
mean transgenderism so much of the
ideology of transgenderism
is about trying to come to grips with
the fact that we all know there's a
metaphysical reality we are not just
clumps of cells we are not just flesh
and bones we are more
than our bodies and yet because the the
world has told us for the past hundred
years that nothing exists outside of
material the people who have gender
dysphoria don't know how to make sense
of that
but speaking of transgenderism what
kinda is saying is you could go to any
public library in America just about and
you could say I won't have a drag queen
story hour and that would be basically
uncontroversial but if you came into
those libraries and said I want to have
a Bible study I want to have a prayer
circle that would be controversial if
you if you went into an elementary
school give you a more clear example if
you went into an elementary school and
said we're gonna have sex education in
kindergarten and talk about
transgenderism and how boys can be girls
and girls can be boys and maybe we'll
bring in a transgender individual to
spread this ideology that would be
uncontroversial at least among the
administrators in fact the only
controversy would be if you said no to
that it would be all wall-to-wall
mainstream media news but if you went
into that same school and said I want
there to be a prayer circle and a Bible
study not only would that be
controversial not only would you be shut
down
that would be dubbed unconstitutional
and that is the absurdity right you can
go in and spread an absurd ideology a a
newt novel ideology that doesn't make
any sense the boys can really be girls
and girls can be boys but only if you
really think so and actually there's 56
genders and since I said that there's
actually a new one so it's 57 genders
you can say that on the one hand you're
encouraged to say that on the other hand
but if you want to read the foundational
work of Western civilization the Bible
that will be dubbed unconstitutional in
schools it's hilarious it's unfortunate
but if you took the suffering out of it
it would be absolutely hilarious and
that is what Kanye is pointing out and
he is saying there is spiritual warfare
and as what he's saying at this church
which is usually all smiles and good old
life advice and not really mentioning
the name of Christ too much he's saying
you have to give your life to Christ if
you are a Christian the center of your
life is Christ and it reminds me of the
st. Michael prayer the st. Michael
prayer the Catholics pray says st.
Michael the Archangel defend us in
battle be our
defense against the wickedness and
snares of the devil may God rebuke him
we humbly pray and do that while Prince
of the heavenly hosts by the power of
God thrust into hell Satan and all the
evil spirits who prowl about the world
seeking the ruin of souls that is not
feel-good happy happy you're gonna make
a lot of money kind of messaging but
that is spiritual reality to Christians
in the true Christian tradition and
unbelievably Kanye West is articulating
it beautifully my maca hat goes off to
him my tip I tip him my mag ahem before
we go I got to talk about Pete Moody
judge right now in Iowa the Democratic
race is being thrown completely on its
head Joe Biden was supposed to be the
leader of the primary that has been
going away for a while now and Elizabeth
Warren has been surging but Elizabeth
Warren isn't the one who's up in Iowa
Pete Budaj
is now leading by nine points in Iowa I
knew something was going on when I got a
text on my phone from 303 303 oh here it
is it's my personal line to Joe Biden
and he texted I mean obviously this is
from his campaign but the campaign
texted it's Joe Biden's campaign manager
Greg yesterday we got a new poll in Iowa
and honestly it's not what we want to
see right now we're tied for third in
Iowa losing Iowa doesn't mean we can't
win but it makes winning the primary
harder and more expensive it's not the
sort of thing you want to be sending out
especially this far in advance
that's the sort of thing you send out
two weeks before the caucus to get your
guys rallied up if you're sending out
that kind of message this early you are
having some serious trouble so what
happened what allowed boo to judge just
to surge boo to judge initially was
doing pretty well running as this kind
of moderate nice amiable guy then he
decided to run to the left and become
pastor Pete and tell Christians that
they're not really Christians and say
that if you're a real Christian actually
you support abortion and just if you're
a real Christian actually you support
all the opposite of Christianity and it
was just so annoying and gaslighting
that he really started to lose traction
his debate was do I go for the Biden
wing or do I go for the Bernie wing when
he saw that Biden started to collapse as
his campaign manager just admitted then
he switched swung back and went for the
the Biden wing and that has been working
since just September Budaj Edge has
risen 16 percentage point among Iowa's
likely Democratic caucus goers 25% now
say that he is their first choice for
president he beats Joe Biden Bernie
Sanders Liz Warren who are now all
clustered around second place I mean
they're almost 10 points behind Budaj
edge now in that last poll in September
Warren was up she was at the top she was
at 22% now Liz Warren is down to 16%
great news for Pete Budaj edge it's
actually backing up what Geoff Andrew
and Barack Obama two Democrats have been
saying about this impeachment the
American people do not want to rip down
their system of government the American
people do not want entrenched interests
to overturn presidential elections the
American people are not paying attention
to this impeachment and they don't want
this kind of radicalism the Democrats
know that they're trying to impeach
Trump because they believe that if they
don't impeach him they won't that the
American people will reelect him that's
what representative Al Green said in
2017 so they're trying to do it even
right before an election year and I
think the American people can see
through this I think that's reflected in
the polls I think even the Democratic
Party can see through this and you're
getting a surge from Budaj edge and the
problem for budda judge is Iowa is great
and it'll give him a lot of momentum
going into the primary but he has
virtually no black support and he's got
some serious racial problems in his
hometown where he's mayor South Bend
Indiana there were some police brutality
allegations and for now he's actually
got a new scandal involving racial
politics which is that Budaj edge has
been falsely claiming to have
endorsements from african-american
leaders to use the popular phrase that
just weren't true a lot of those people
actually were white he then used a stock
photo from Africa to
picked african-americans that's a little
bit of a faux pas and he's he's just not
gaining traction among black voters and
that's gonna especially matter in South
Carolina that is Joe Biden's firewall
right now Biden still doing very well in
South Carolina South Carolina is much
blacker state in Iowa that's for sure
so the you can't win the nomination for
the Democratic Party without black
voters and if you're a Democrat you
can't win the general without black
voters if Pete Buddha judge can figure
out a way to get black voters to come
over to his campaign he will very likely
be the strongest candidate in the race
before we go I have to just read out an
amazing tweet from President Trump this
was really terrific you might have seen
the headline over the weekend that Kim
jong-un of North Korea went for the
jugular against Joe Biden Kim jong-un
said that Biden had quote the temerity
to dare slander the dignity of the
supreme leadership of the DPRK that's
the official name of North Korea it is
the last-ditch efforts of the rabid dog
expediting his death it's about Joe
Biden rabid dogs like Biden can hurt
lots of people if they are allowed to
run out of control
they must be beaten to death with a
stick before it is too late that is not
the onion or the bath Allonby that is
the actual press release from North
Korea and this comes after it in May Kim
jong-un referred to Joe Biden as the
quote fool of low IQ and a quote
imbecile bereft of elementary quality as
a human being
show me the lie show me the lie no
that's not fair and even President Trump
who is always accused of siding with
dictators over his domestic political
adversaries actually came out and
defended Joe Biden in what I felt was a
beautiful way he tweeted out quote mr.
chairman Joe Biden may be sleepy and
very slow but he is not a rabid dog he
is actually somewhat better than that
but I am the only one who can get you
where you have to be you should act
quickly get the deal done see you soon
this is the perfect rebuke to kim
jeong-hoon he's not really vociferously
defending Joe Biden that would be diss
ingenuine and uncalled-for but he's also
not letting this foreign dictator just
absolutely annihilate the former vice
president of the United States with his
rhetoric he's hitting this middle ground
and he's doing what he does best which
is tell a little joke about it defend
America and try to advance his agenda
that ultimately is much much more
appealing than a coup d'etat by federal
bureaucrats conspiring with Democrats
and leftist donors to overturn a
presidential election because Trump is
hurting the feelings of career
bureaucrats that that is not going to
play in Peoria that's not going to play
with the American people and you're
seeing that reflected in the polls
you're seeing the smart guys and the
Democrats pushing the bricks but I don't
think they can stop now
they are so far gone ultimately though
the conservative consolation is that
reality reasserts itself in the end we
are seeing that competition between the
imaginary fantasy world of the
bureaucrats and the reality of the
American electorate
well that election is coming up fast and
the American people are going to get
their say once again that's our show on
Michael Knowles this is the Michael Nolt
show come on out to the University of
Kentucky tonight we're gonna have a lot
of fun and otherwise I'll see you
tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy bore
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis clever
and our technical producer is Austin
Stephens assistant director pavel why
douse key edited by danny D'Amico audio
is mixed by my core amina hair and
makeup is by Jessa alvera and our
production assistant is Nick Sheehan the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19 on
the Matt Walsh oh we're not just
discussing politics we're talking
culture faith family all of the things
that are really important to you so come
join the conversation
you